At this point, hopefully you feel like you can attack a new big
investigation bring it within the scope of a statistical inference problem and
then apply iterations of the QMV process to gradually hone a solution.
You've seen a taste of what model building and
data analysis problems looks like in the real world.
And how it is a continual process of investigation.
Finding results and
then proposing new lines of investigation based upon those results.
Sometimes, retrying or adjusting previous decisions.
Specifically, we get the process going by iterating on
an initial question until we arrive at answers to the following.
What metrics will be used to capture the phenomenon?
What statistical inference problem will be examined?
What features will inform the inference problem?
Once we've determined how to measure the problem as well as what form of
question we'll be answering, we enter the modeling phase in which we
choose a method for answering this question.
This method should take advantage of structure within data to
achieve maximum effectiveness.
Lastly, once we've built the model, we evaluate how good the model is at
generalizing to the wider phenomenon in the validation phase.